so we are with Guyana garcía bernal
international heartthrob and the star of
rosewater we are an exercise I'm gonna
ask you about a very serious issue
unrelated to the movie first you you do
come from Mexico I think I know I do and
I do want to ask you to comment on the
43 missing students and Guerrero who are
now reportedly killed I feel almost you
know without words because nothing we
say right now nothing we do everything
this is how this is a farce compared to
what's happening in real life yeah what
happened there is much more important
than anything we're doing here
so let's first divide things so that's
not I mean it's not a comment one can do
easily why because it is a one of the
most incredibly hurtful things that has
happened to Mexico over the last in in
its history we are
ashamed angered we're fed up where I
don't know I feel I feel it's just
incredibly terrible and I'm I'm glad
we're able to talk about this but it
does feel like it is far much more
important than anything we're doing like
an interview even you know like it's
it's a it's a big issue that needs to be
and talked about there's a lot of
demonstrations that have to happen we
all have to support that not only people
in Mexico with people from the outside
world we need them to help us stop this
how can I help how can I help them out
for many ways many ways many ways
there's no real answer and they in a way
like it's an interview isn't gonna solve
things sorry I'm it's a bigger thing it
is it is a bigger the impunity is so big
that no words I can say right now I do
want to talk about the movie do you see
any parallels in terms of what
journalists face in Mexico and what
journalist wave in Iran absolutely yeah
and face in many parts of the world
I mean there is a big crisis of power
going on right now everywhere in the
world and power is trying to find its
way staying in power controlling things
and there is professional journalism
journalists there is non professional
journalists that are doing sometimes
equally as important job and so we're
not wind an interesting situation where
where where unfortunately the only
people that can tell the stories of all
these massacres that occur of all these
disappearances of all this violence all
this injustice are the journalists
without journalism there exists no
democracy and so it is I mean this film
highlights that issue like an intense
reflection with what's happening in
Mexico definitely young I can say is now
a rallying cry for the movement
demanding justice for the students I've
had enough of the war on drugs I've had
enough of them taking us before